ان تعرف اكثر شعار قناه العربيه عبر
السنوات ما هذا الطريقه لولاده منصه
المحتوى رقم الجديده اكثر اكثر تهدف
لتوسيع نطاق محتوى العربيه الرقميه
واستهدف المزيد من الفئه العمريه حدث
اطلاق اكثر شهد اطلاقا ثمانيه برامج رقميه
جديده تركز على مجموعه متنوعه تشمل
الرعايه الصحيه والغذاء والسفر والفن
والسيارات والجديد في عالم التقنيه هو
برنامج يبسط المشهد السياسي بالاضافه
لبرنامج حول العمله الرقميه العربيه تظن
ملايين المتابعين عبر جميع حساباتها على
منصات التواصل واكثر خطوه اضافيه للحفاظ
على رياده المؤسسات في المنطقه
منذ البدايه كان هدفنا ان تعرف اكثر فكنا
اكثر قربا وصدقا ومهنيا واليوم سنحفظكم في
رحله الى عالم بابعاد جديده لتكون على بعد
ضغطه زر واحده لتعيش معنا
اكثر عفويه
[موسيقى]
النجاح تستدعي ان نفكر اكثر خارج حدود
في الاستوديو تنضم الينا فرح الابراهيم
فرح يسعد صباحك اهلا بك شكرا على تواجد
معنا في الاستديو منصه جديده رقميه
للعربيه حدثينا اكثر الجميع يتساءل ما هي
اكثر طبعا ما قصرتي يعني المقدمه كمان
كانت شامله وافيه اكثر هي منصه رقميه همم
باور باي العربيه تشمل البرامج عديده
مستهدفين فيها الشباب اللي قاعدين على
الجوالاتهم يبون الماده السريعه الخفيفه
الظريفه فاكثر هدفها هو خلق محتوى عصري
شبابي يستهدف هذا الشريحه الشباب الشباب
هل كان افضل ان تحاط بالسريه حتى نرى
النتيجه والعرض المبهريه وما امس من قبل
لكم يعني هذا جزء من التسويق انه نشتغل
عليها على نار هادئه وكمان جزء من الانتاج
اللي تبعنا يعني يعني احنا بدانا تقريبا
من 2019
بانتاج البرامج الديجيتال واطلقناها كان
سوفت لانش مثل ما يقولون
فشفنا ان الوقت الان مناسب ان احنا نطلقها
بشكل تحت مظله واحده بضم جميع البرامج
انها تستهدف الشباب الذين يستخدمون
موبايلاتهم وتحدثين بالتفصيل عن البرامج
التي تشملها اكثر اكيد عندنا طبعا برامج
منوعه في كافه المجالات عندنا
فايبر لايف ستايل في السياره الى الموتورز
والسيارات كمان عندنا شيء تاكل
التكنولوجيا سياسه همم اكسبلينغ او شرح
الاحداث التاريخيه والمصطلحات السياسيه
واشياء عديده يعني
طيب فرح يوم امس في هذا العرض في مذيعه
استفزتني شوي هي مذيعه روبوت
ما هي ميرا وشو راح تعمل وش راح يكون
دورها ولا وين حدودها او شيء شكرا انك
قدمتي الحفل نادين كنت ضعيفه معانا رائعه
الصراحه وانبسطنا بوجودك كثير وحبيت
تعليقك على ميرا انه لا تاخذي مكاننا في
مستحيل اعلام هي ميرا صراحه تجربه احنا
كثير متحمسين عليها ميرا افاتار عملناه
همم يقدم برنامج خاص عن التكنولوجيا
المستقبل
فراح نشوف كيف ردود فعل الناس على وجود
افاتار يقدم البرنامج امير على فكره خفيفه
الدم كثير ظريفه واا راح تتفاعل مع الناس
راح تتفاعل مع تعليقاتهم ايضا همم راح
نشوف بتحسين نشوف النتيجه راح تنطلق اليوم
ان شاء الله على المنصه طيب العربيه يعني
تضم ملايين المتابعين لا حساباتها كيف
تختلف اكثر على هذه الحسابات
عفوا اكثر كيف تختلف على منصات العربيه
الاخرى العربيه غالبا اخباريا اكيد تقدم
محتوى اكيد مختلف ومتنوع لكن اكثر ال- همم
التون او النبره المتوجه فيها شبابيه اكثر
حيويه اكثر سوشيال ميديا اكثر يعني احنا
في مصطلحات الكونتن جورنايتد 4 بلس
من سؤال سهام بلا سؤالي بهذا الموضوع قناه
العربيه قناه اخباريه اوكي ومنصه اكثر
الرقميه هي موجهه للشباب فئه عمريه معينه
وبتتواكب مع السوشيال ميديا لكن في لينك
معين او رابط قناه العربيه كاخباريه وبينك
العربيه
اكثر يعني العربيه مش قد يكون لها جمهور
العربيه من 15 سنه
بفئات عمريه محدده توجهات محدده عندهم
توقعات معينه انه العربيه اشهر محتوى اللي
راح تقدمه لهم فاكثر هي تابعه للعربيه
ولكن مستهدفه الى شريحه جديده فئات عمريه
جديده فطبيعه الحال اسلوب الطرح راح يكون
مختلف شكرا جزيلا الفرح الابراهيم اتمنى
كل التوفيق اكثر شكرا لكم شكرا
[موسيقى]